Good morning John, it's Tuesday.
I am right now on the set of Wil Wheaton's
TableTop RPG show.
I have been having an amazing time here going
on adventures in a custom designed campaign
that Wil made for me, Yuri Lowenthal, Laura
Bailey, and Alison Haislip.
John, I've been discovering the weirdnesses
of Snapchat and I decided to do a question
video today, and the questions are all gonna
come from Snapchat.
What did you play with Wil?
We've been playing a brand new RPG that did
not exist before but it's called Titansgrave:
The Ashes of Valkana.
It's sort of sci-fi mixed with fantasy world.
If you could remove an element from the periodic
table, which one would you choose?
I assume we're talking about removing an element
of the periodic table from the world because
you can't just remove an element from the
periodic table, that doesn't do anything;
it's just less knowledge that we have then.
I think I'd probably pick one of the more
dangerous ones.
Like if we had less plutonium in the world,
I don't know that that would be a bad thing.
What is your songwriting process?
Usually I start with like one good line that
I really love that has really great rhythm
and that I can kind of start a melody around.
If I love that line enough, then it gives
me the desire to work hard to create a song
around it, so it's more how do I inspire myself
to want to write a song than "how do I actually
write the song?"
'Cause if I want it bad enough I feel like
it's just gonna happen.
How are you liking Snapchat so far?
That's a lovely elephant!
Snapchat is weird.
I don't think that I use it the way that most
people use it.
Because, I, you know, I already have an audience,
and so I'm kind of just trying to make people
laugh and have a good time, and it's a really
great format for that because I don't have
to worry about the things being, like, part
of my permanent record.
I feel more free to just mess around and be
dumb, which is important to me.
Favorite national park?
I'm gonna go with Yellow - ooh!
I kicked a die box!
Sorry dice!
- I'm gonna go with Yellowstone National Park
'cause it is weird!
It is an amazing magical place; it's got a
lot of geological weirdness and biological
weirdness.
How cute is my banana monkey?
Your banana monkey is cute; I am worried about
where its legs are.
Who do you normally play as on Mario Kart?
I'm a Donkey Kong man, uh, Mario Kart and
Smash Brothers.
I just need the extra beef.
I'm not a finesse player.
What's your favorite kitchen utensil?
That is a weird question!
I - maybe a colander?
Why do dogs get eye boogers too?
Dogs get eye boogers for the same reason we
do.
There's stuff that comes out of your eye -- it's
usually, it's dissolved in your tears.
It's called rheum, and it contains all kinds
of stuff you probably don't want to know about
like blood cells and epithelial cells, um,
and also mucus.
When the water leaves mucus, the stuff it
leaves behind is the mucan compounds, which
are proteins, which are sort of gummy and
gross.
And dogs have just as much of that stuff as
we do; I think most mammals or all mammals,
ah, even get that goin' on.
Best Buy employees love SciShow apparently.
That's not a question, but thank you for letting
me know!
That's cool.
LASAGNA CUPCAKES!
Yeah, also not a question!
If there are two dogs and one cat, how many
fish are there?
As far as I can tell, the number of dogs and
cats has no bearing on the number of fish.
Why haven't you done a dance vid in a while?
[music]
John, I'm really excited about this show;
it's gonna be coming out in June so it's gonna
be a while before everybody gets to see it.
But we have been having an amazing time with
these little dice, and I'm excited to share
it with all of you!
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.